These villagers thought they were safe after
escaping the tsunami that tore through the
western coast of Java.
But now that they've returned, they face a
new problem.
Around 6 in the morning, the water began rising.
I went out to get some food, and when I came
back, the water was almost chest high.
Our village has never been flooded like this.
Johnny moved his family because of the chance
of another tsunami.
In this home behind me he lives with 25 others.
It’s a tight squeeze, he says, but at least
they are living among family members, they’re
all accounted for and alive.
All his has now is his faith and his family.
Johnny's wife Maesaroh remembers the moment
she had to leave.
When I heard talk of a second tsunami coming,
I grabbed my children and ran to my sister’s
house.
People were panicking and fleeing, screaming,
'Run!
Run!' because the wave was coming.
I couldn’t think of anything else, the safety
of my children was my only priority.
My youngest children are 8 and 3 years old.
They're in a bit of a shock and have trouble
sleeping.
So while the tsunami spared this family, the
floods still threaten their lives.